oscar-winning director spike lee he's
got another masterpiece on his hands
with the upcoming netflix military drama
the five bloods
what i thought was a teaching moment in
this film was showing how the traumas of
our past
stay with us to this day you have a film
out
that speaks to the times it's so
relevant i see ghosts
the vietnam war was televised
into american homes so 67 out of 10
years old
having to undergo heavy small arms and
mortar fire
i'm also watching on television the
demonstrations here too
yeah so i remember this i remember dr
king
being assassinated you know i remember
rfk being assassinated
i remember richard nixon resigning you
know
i was alive spike is helping us
understand more about the black american
experience into five bloods
four african-american vets returned to
vietnam searching for a fallen soldier
played by chadwick boseman
while there they relived the racial
inequalities
black soldiers faced while fighting for
their country anybody coming to watch
this film
specifically watching these black men
if they can take some or all of those
aspects of the film and then apply them
to how they walk through the world i'll
be a very happy uh
camper being back here it is not easy
there were two wars that they were
fighting they were fighting the war
and then they were fighting their own
battles with people that were in their
platoon
that brother was the best damn soldier
that ever lived when you know better you
do better
and that's something that we're um i
think i think we're really offering with
this family
the film comes at this moment in time
when people are grieving
and searching for solutions on how to
make life equal
for everyone how's everybody's hearts
how's everybody doing
it goes in waves it goes away right now
this is healing right here
it's okay to cry it's okay to laugh what
you don't want to do is
just hold all of that in that's probably
the problem is that a lot of this has
just been
held in let it out you know in little
steps
let those emotions out do you feel like
there's a shift
in this country only time will tell
we'll take the hope that we're feeling
now
and let it fuel ourselves into the
future the gap
between the have have nots is this has
to be closed
across the board
[Music]